creation of a circle here X minus H the
quantity squared plus y minus K the
quantity squared equals the radius
squared so go ahead and memorize that
but you also want to remember that each
and K those are the center of the circle
the center point of the circle and then
R here is the radius now notice this is
the radius squared you would have to
take the square root of this quantity to
find the actual radius so an example
would be say this is an equation here of
a circle in standard form you can see
that the center is actually going to be
at positive 2 negative 3 notice that the
signs are the opposite and then the
radius is going to be the square root of
9 which is 3 ok so that's just a basic
example this is already set up for us
the problems that are on the SAT are
slightly more challenging and that's
what we're gonna get into right now so
see if you can pause the video do these
problems on your own we'll go through
them together and talk about how to
approach them but the first one that
says write the equation of a circle with
endpoints on the diameter of negative 2
comma 3 and 6 9 so go ahead and see if
you can solve that one we'll do it
together
so here's the thing you might want to
draw just a quick sketch here negative
2/3 is somewhere right here 6 9 is
somewhere over here the circle is gonna
look something like this we're trying to
find that center point and we're also
trying to find out what the radius is
right okay so the thing is to find this
center point if these are the endpoints
of the diameter right we're gonna have
to use our midpoint formula ok so the
midpoint formula another one that's
helpful you might want to memorize if
you don't know this one already it's the
average of the X's and it's the average
of the Y's so just like you would think
you're adding the x-coordinates together
and dividing by 2
adding the Y corners together and
dividing by 2 so if we do that we get
negative 2 plus 6 divided by 2 and 3
plus 9 divided by 2 which we simplify
that it's going to be 4 over 2 which is
2 12 over 2 which is 6 so now we know
that the center of our circle is at 2
comma 6 right right 2 up 6 so so far
what we have is X minus 2 squared plus y
minus 6 squared right equals the radius
squared ok now to find the radius you
can do a couple different things
one thing you can do is you can say well
I know that my Center here is at two six
I know that a point over here on the
circle is six nine you could use the
distance formula to find that radius put
it in here and then square it so just a
quick reminder the distance formula is
the square root of x2 minus x1 squared
plus y2 minus y1 squared you add those
together and you take the square root
that's one way to do it another way to
do it this way I like is you just take
one of the points let's just say we take
six nine if we put six in for X okay so
that's six minus two squared we put nine
in for Y so that's 9 minus 6 squared we
can solve for R squared that's going to
be 4 squared which is 16 3 squared which
is 9 so you can see that R squared is
actually going to be 25 so if we put
this all back together our equation of
our circle is X minus 2 squared plus y
minus 6 squared equals the radius
squared which is 25 and you got it okay
example number two see if you can do
this one on your own the equation of a
circle is given by this equation here
what is the center of the circle so
they're just asking us for the center
but notice that this equation is not in
our standard form of a circle so we're
gonna have to put in that standard form
so we can identify the coordinates of
the center so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do this on your own
we'll go ahead and go through it
together the first thing I would do is I
would group the axis together so I'd say
x squared minus 6x and I'd grouped the
Y's together so Y squared plus 4y seemed
just grouping these together equals
three okay now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna complete the square so to
complete the square what we have here is
we have like a trinomial so you
trinomials three terms like this right
and what you're going to want to do is
you're going to take half of this middle
coefficient so half of negative six okay
divide it by you know half of it divided
by two and square it so negative six
divided by two is negative three
negative three squared is nine so I'm
going to add nine but if I add nine to
the left side of the equation I have to
add nine to the right because you're
trying to keep it balanced you don't
want to change the overall equation same
thing here gonna take half of 4 which is
2 and then square it which is 4
if we add four to the left we want to
add four to the right so if we simplify
here you can see this is coming out to
16 now what we're going to do is we're
going to factor these trinomials now the
way we've set it up by completing the
square
is that these are perfect squares okay
so this is going to be X minus three
squared and y plus two squared
now you can double-check that by taking
X minus 3 times X minus 3 C twice
foiling it you'll get back this original
but a quick shortcut is if you want to
figure out how I got this you can just
take half of this middle coefficient see
X minus 3 take half of this coefficient
half of positive 4 is positive 2 or plus
2 that's a quick way to just go ahead
and you know write these perfect squares
here ok so there you go so that's the
equation of your circle right there the
center is going to be at positive 3
negative 2 now some students make the
mistake of saying negative 3 positive 2
but it's actually the opposite sign
because you can see it's X minus H y
minus K so you can see X minus so it's
actually positive 3 and y plus 2 is
actually like Y minus a negative 2 so
it's actually negative 2 or you can just
remember that there's the opposite sign
so this is your center point here 3
negative 2 if you need to go ahead and
review this lesson again this is
definitely an important concept to
understand for the SAT and an easy one
to get right if you can understand the
basic equation of the circle and how to
complete the square
I'll see you in the next lesson